[Music]
the one last night was
the last thing i saw was um
mckenzie trying to get back with connor
and then
oh okay yeah you're not carrington tries
to break it up yeah so
that's how funny is that [ __ ] he's like
he walks over
can i steal him for a second it's really
important it's like what could possibly
be
important in the in the [ __ ] villa
there's nothing going on
man like first of all
connor bless that guy's heart man
he's just so he's just oh
man i don't know he's just
it's like he's in middle school you know
no it's like he's 10 years old man
yeah yeah yeah like exactly like a fifth
grader
yeah it's just i don't even know how
that i mean that guy's an accountant
i'd be terrified if that guy was doing
my plan
horrified when he walked in holding the
teddy bear
ah i felt something
so bad just in my soul i was like you
poor poor dude
[Laughter]
if you're not watching love island this
season basically this school goes to
caso moore and
his lady is like basically hooking up
with this other dude talking about how
oh and the [ __ ] mental gymnastics
that she did oh yeah the worst part is
that she pressured him into the
relationship basically he didn't want to
be in it he didn't actually like her but
she kept manipulating him she's so
like emotionally manipulative like any
time he was
trying to be honest she would just break
down and cry and so he would he
she like kind of trained him not to do
that yeah not to open up
so eventually he was just scared to like
not to break up with her basically he
wanted to
but she wouldn't let him yeah so he's
stuck in this relationship and then he
goes to
castle more which is when they go to a
separate house with all new dudes and
then
at the end of three or four days they
yeah all new dudes the six guys go to
hang out with six other guys
just to chill no no
there's just 12 guys hanging
i bet they'd be stoked they'd be like
more bros
yes let's do it beer pong let's set it
up
um no they go to hang out with all new
girls the girls get
a whole new cast of dudes in their house
yeah and then they they
you know they flirt they crack on for
like three four days and then
at the end the girls have to decide
whether they're gonna pick one of the
new guys
yeah the guy does the same thing and the
guy has to walk into the girls
back into the original house yeah they
either walk in with someone or they walk
in alone right
and they see whether or not their girl
that they were with before is sitting on
the couch with a new guy or sitting
alone
and so and so mackenzie picks this new
guy she
she like you know basically flirts with
this new guy
gets along with him great sudden she's
like conor's not that
cool anymore and i don't know why i was
ever with him just with it
just like handbagging conor like yeah
crazy
like just like oh he's [ __ ] sucks and
yeah
and and like it's like well when i think
about it he was the one who wasn't
just ignoring all the other [ __ ] dark
[ __ ] she did
yeah and then this dude comes connor
comes walking in
with this with her teddy bear that she
sent him which is [ __ ]
up that she sent him that while hooking
up with another guy basically to keep
him at bay
and then he's like he's like oh it
smells like her it smells like mackenzie
ugh and then meanwhile she's just
[ __ ] playing tonsil hockey with this
other guy
tatted up too this dude's like six foot
tall tatted
dyed blonde hair perfect smile right
that's who she's flirting with meanwhile
mackenzie is smelling this teddy bear
she left them yeah and not flirting with
anyone else because he's like no i'm
staying loyal
and i hated i hated that that when
he walked in with the bear she acted
like it was a surprise
yeah oh my god he walked in when barnaby
whatever the [ __ ] that bear's name is
and then she made it about herself she
made the whole thing about herself and
that
that whole situation with the hideaway
like god damn they picked a perfect
villain
oh my god i haven't seen somebody that's
spoiled in forever
yeah that bro wow
wow oh the high the hideaway when they
got it and or when they
when like they got a text that said the
highway was open and yeah
well come on connor and everyone was
like we should talk about this and then
she used the words i want it
and everyone goes all right the best
part is when
do we already talk about this when she
starts going down on him oh yeah yeah
and he's like giggling and all that
is like giggling yeah um anyways the
show is incredible this is no we
here's one thing we didn't get in that
whole scenario which is the worst
she goes use the bidet it's crazy and he
goes
all right and i could tell in his soul
he didn't want to sit on that thing he
didn't
and he goes and he uses it he's like
that was crazy
whoa i've never seen someone else
hostage
so bad yeah like that like his his
demeanor
was um
you know it was like front row to open
mic yeah that's the whole
like yeah he has to laugh he has to
respond
hey man who who are you here with
tonight uh just you know
myself man cool man cool this joke is
for you
there's at least like seven other people
here man it doesn't have to be
no it's about you man okay go away
this is my guy he's gonna laugh yeah i
love comedy
i love comedy i love to sit here and
watch
the worst part about the whole thing is
that after after that
happened the next couple days the dude
that the new guy with mckenzie realizes
that she is
indeed crazy and so they end up like
kind of
splitting up and she goes back to connor
and somehow gets him to kind of almost
consider going back with her
dude like how brutal is that dude he
look man man oh man
so i appreciated carrington
just trying to split it up yeah and and
i was
crying laughing when when when john
when johnny and kayla when he came when
he comes back and they
they like they cut to her and she's like
um
and they cut to the dudes and they're
like you don't owe her
anything they're really trying to drill
it through his head
oh she stinks yeah yeah and even the
girls are like connor
you can't you just you can't
and even the dudes to mackenzie even
carrington to mackenzie was like listen
i love you
but you [ __ ] put this dude through so
much yeah just
back off yeah just leave him alone live
go away just [ __ ] go away
bro and then what's so funny is it when
when she's talking about jalen the other
dude she's hugging up with and then the
girl is like well maybe this and that
she just starts crying she's like
i thought i thought it was about me
and like no one's talking about my
feelings it's just like and they're like
uh we're just trying to
give you what he might have meant by
that just
a little bit of perspective and everyone
in that room was like okay
as soon as she starts that as soon as
she does that face where she's like but
i
oh jesus [ __ ] christ here we go again
and it's not even like real crying
yeah you know what i mean like it's just
like the feel bad for me face
that's just oh man please little
sympathy
it's it's kind of it's it's perfect
though to pick the perfect person
them too it's yeah
it's great it's just this season is so
so [ __ ] great so
this is so basically i don't think
you've watched this far yet this isn't
really a spoiler but
three new guys enter and like
two or three episodes in one of them
just disappears
and and everyone on twitter is like i
was on a oh i was on an instagram
comment thread and i was reading because
they're all like what the [ __ ] happened
to this guy what happened to this guy
apparently someone found him in gay porn
and i guess he like didn't tell the
producers or something before he got
casted and so they
kicked him off for it whoa yeah this is
all through instagram comments so i
don't know if it's true
that's a great ass rumor but someone
posted someone posted the link and there
was like three people that responded
they were like oh my god that is him
that is him oh come on man
so what is so was it i did it
i didn't click it i didn't
all right i clicked it but you know i
clicked let me just say this guy could
sit on a cake
all right okay exactly this guy could
sit on a cake
no i could tell by the ass it's
definitely it's definitely him
you